[Musique]
adieu baudroie un dieu joue le rôle du
fou et oui les enfants nous partons en
voyage ce très grand voyage nous partons
très loin je descend vite faire mes
adieux avec deux petits amis patrons et
puis on s'en va pour les châles les
mains d'une foule à saluer ma droit le
long hall mots
lol lol lol hollande
et bien joué
j'ai une grande nouvelle à vous annoncer
les enfants
partons en voyage
[Musique]
cette fois c'est différent nous allons
dans un pays que je ne connais pas un
pays merveilleux
nous allons aux arts
vous ne partagez pas ma joie
en rester à la maison et on ira au
jardin mais je vous raconterai une autre
voyage dans ce pays et roland
aller
que de choses extraordinaires à voir que
tu nous rapportera des choses
le temps a chez kana c'est loin disait
oh
notre petit nuage va avoir un long
trajet a peur vous alles est fatigué oui
sommes invités chez legrand maharaja
mais l'anah à carreaux
[Musique]
des cheveux mais l'anah à part on
possède les plus beaux jardins du monde
plein de fleurs merveilleux
si il part qui permet à tous les petits
enfants du pays de venir jouer dans ces
gens
énormément
qu'est ce que tu cherches
du tissu si vous aviez un morceau de
tissu à me prêter je voudrais me faire
une coiffure
tout mais bien sûr nous tiens je n'ai
pas faim c'est exactement ce qu'il me
faut à tout de suite
bien j'ai une idée
[Musique]
tu as raison nicolas kalfa line poupe et
une otan une raquette et on le remercie
notre provisions bonbons
[Musique]
[Rires]
connaissez rien je suis sûr que le grand
marat cha mais la nappe à carreaux porte
exactement la même coiffure
[Musique]
au
ces pour mon voyage non c'est pour les
petits enfants de là bas allez fais un
bon voyage je reviens vite ce promu
apportez-nous kaka wybo l'onu
à bientôt en hausse
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
allons-nous nours dépêche-toi patron je
suis prêt à partir
oui tu es beau tu n'as pas peur que ton
turban s'envole vous avez raison je
l'enlève je le remettrais en arrivant là
bas en route aux routes à bientôt les
enfants nous reviendront vite vous voir
bonne nuit les petits
à bientôt
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouveau
[Musique]
m